das ist nicht nur die letzte
Sitzungswoche in diesem Jahr es ist
sogar der Letzte Sitzungstag und wie ist
der Bundestag so will hat er noch mal
und das Programm einfach nicht
aufgemischt hat zwei Tagesordnungspunkte
nach vorne geschoben die ursprünglich
gar nicht da gewesen sind nämlich es
geht um den Schutz des sogenannter
Whistleblower und um die Stärkung der
Bundespolizei uns hat das nicht
angefochten wer sie bei dem Thema
geblieben dass wir sowieso vorhatten um
diese Zeit dann geht es nämlich um das
Engagement und haben das Ehrenamt also
freiwilliges Engagement da liegt dann
als dritter Tagesordnungspunkt heute der
sogenannte dritte engagementberichte der
Bundesregierung es ist die vorige
Bundesregierung übrigens noch gewesen
vor und wird hier diskutiert und wir
fanden da ist so viel Thema drin und so
viel Stoff und so viel interessante
Punkte dass wir das durchaus auch an
dieser Stelle immer diskutieren sollten
und wir können das machen weil der die
große Frage ist wie wird sich das in
Zukunft entwickeln wir heute von vielen
Egoismen in der Gesellschaft
gleichzeitig wächst der Bedarf an auch
freiwilligen im Engagement und die Frage
ist halt wie lässt sich da die Waage
finden und da sollen wir jetzt mal
besprechen vorab schon mal wird
hellgelehnt der ist Sprecher der AG
Demokratie in der SPD-Bundestagsfraktion
und bei uns ist außerdem Volker Ulrich
der Innen- und rechtspolitische Sprecher
der CSU Landesgruppe ihnen beiden guten
Morgen schön dass Sie da sind Herr Lindt
als Bundestagsabgeordneter habe ich
gesehen sie sind in 14 Vereinen bzw
Organisationen Mitglied haben außerdem
noch zwei kommunalpolitische Mandate
welches ehrenamtliche welche
ehrenamtliche Tätigkeit haben Sie
zuletzt noch ausgeübt
also ganz aktuell ist es wahrscheinlich
der 15 Verein weil ich Vorsitzender des
Pina Baus Fördervereins in meinem heiß
geliebten Wuppertal geworden
es sind wahrscheinlich noch viel mehr
Vereine also ich versuche trotz allem
trotz aller berufspolitischen Arbeit
diese Erdung durchs Ehrenamt noch weiter
zu treiben aber ohne allzu viele Posten
zu sammeln das ist nämlich auch eine
Gefahr der man als Politiker täglich
ausgesetzt ist wie sieht es bei Ihnen
aus der Ulrich Ehrenamt gehört zu ihrem
Arbeitskreis den sie leiten
ja ganz persönlich habe ich mich mit der
Wahl in den Deutschen Bundestag von der
Spitze oder vom Vorstand mehrerer
Vereine zurückgezogen um mich auf Mann
mein Mandat konzentrieren zu können
gleichwohl bin ich Mitglied in
zahlreichen Fördervereinen bei einer
freiwilligen Feuerwehr bei Kolping ich
bin natürlich kein aktiver Feuerwehr das
muss ich auch dazu sagen aber ich
fördere eine freiwillige Feuerwehr in
Augsburg und ich finde der Kontakt mit
den Menschen auf zahlreiche
Mitgliederversammlungen die diese
Vereine und Organisation am Laufen
halten sind nicht nur wichtig für die
politische Arbeit hier sondern zeigen
diese ganze Fülle großartigen
Engagements in eine Gesellschaft und
zeigt uns auch wie lebendig Engagement
Ehrenamt doch sein kann und wie wichtig
ist haben wir eben auch gehört und es
gibt immer viel Lob und Anerkennung bei
offiziellen Gelegenheiten sie beide
haben sie ja eben auch gemacht völlig zu
Recht im übrigen aber wird es trotzdem
hinreichend gewürdigt jenseits der
warmen Worte nein eindeutiges nein aus
meiner Sicht man muss ja so sehen wenn
man es mal beschreiben will dass
Ehrenamt ist ja sowas wie so eine
Keimzelle für Respekt und Aufmerksamkeit
also wir haben das gesehen für Themen
Klimaschutz flüchtlingskrise teilweise
armuts Bekämpfung also bei vielen
relevanten Themen war wenn man genau
hinguckt dass Ehrenamt viel schneller
und pragmatischer und und automatischer
und ideologischer als die politische
Debatte oft erleben wir aber dann das
nach dem Bekundungen sehr großartig was
ihr macht und auch Ehrung in der langen
Strecke die Unterstützung fehlt und das
ist auch die Rückmeldung wie ich oft
bekomme von Ehrenamtlichen dass sie sich
im Stich gelassen fühlen deshalb ist da
noch dringender
handlungsunterstützungsbedarf welche
welche Unterstützung würden Sie für
zwingend halten jetzt mal so langsam
meine ganz persönliche Beobachtung und
Einschätzung ist dass viele Menschen die
sich ehrenamtlich engagieren zunächst
gar nicht danach fragen bekommen sie von
Seiten des Staates dafür eine Belohnung
sondern sie machen es für sich selbst
aber vor allen Dingen auch für andere
Menschen
Senioren die in den Schulen Vorlesen
Menschen die für fahrfeste Kuchen backen
Sie machen es einfach um einen Beitrag
für die Gesellschaft zu leisten dass
darüber hinaus die Frage steht wie kann
der Staat besser die Menschen
unterstützen oder ihnen auch Anerkennung
sollen die sich jahrelang ehrenamtlich
engagieren das meine ich ist noch davon
zu trennen okay ich glaube wir brauchen
noch eine stärkere Anerkennungskultur im
Ehrenamt vor allen Dingen aber auch die
Frage wie können wir dafür Sorge tragen
dass in vielen
bedeutende kritischen Bereichen des
Ehrenamtes Katastrophenschutz Feuerwehr
Rettungsdienst auch die Vereinbarkeit
übrigens von Ehrenamt und Beruf stärker
und einen Hut gebracht werden kann aber
bleiben wir da mal bei was wäre denn
ihre konkreten Vorschläge also wir
setzen voraus die Leute machen das
tatsächlich freiwillig und warten nicht
auf
großartigen Lohn gleichwohl brauchen Sie
Unterstützung beispielsweise wenn sie
irgendwo hinfahren müssen dass der
vielleicht ein Ticket kriegen für einen
öffentlichen Personen Nahverkehr oder
ähnliche Dinge wie kann das konkret
aussehen ich kann mir vorstellen dass
wir zum einen im Steuerrecht etwas tun
eine Art der Ehrenamtspauschale im
Steuerrecht ich kann mir vorstellen dass
wir gerade auch für junge Menschen die
sich engagieren auch
gewisse benefits ausreichen die
entscheidende Frage ist auch die wie ein
Stück weit auch die Freistellung vom
Beruf passieren kann
klar Ehrenamt ist nicht der Beruf aber
ich finde schon dass gerade wenn es um
Feuerwehr geht da gibt es gesetzliche
Ansprüche aber es müsste vielleicht an
dem ein oder anderen Fall auch noch
einfacher gehen wenn ich jetzt haben sie
gerade beide festgestellt irgendwie dass
es da enorme Defizite gibt und jetzt
frage ich sie beide in der
hintereinander irgendwie warum ist er
bislang noch nichts passiert wenn der
der Tatbestand ist doch ist ist bekannt
die die Leistung der Menschen wird
anerkannt deswegen habe ich wir haben am
Anfang auch sehr vehement gesagt nein es
wird es wird zu wenig getan warum
passiert dann nichts weil Demokratie in
unserem Land oft langsam ist was auch
nicht schlecht ist weil wir lange braten
und weil glaube ich die Wachsamkeit und
die Aufmerksamkeit für Ehrenamt erst in
letzter Zeit im politischen Raum so
gewachsen ist und man sieht ja das was
passiert wir haben eine Deutsche
Stiftung für Engagement und Ehrenamt
dies lange nicht gab in der letzten
Legislatur übrigens noch in der großen
Koalition auf den Weg gebracht das wird
künftig hoffentlich an Demokratie
fördergesetz geben also die Botschaft
ist leider spät angekommen und nicht nur
in den Kommunen sondern hier im
politischen Raum und ich glaube um das
neue ergänzen können wir können auch
wenn wir das
Gemeinnützigkeitsrecht uns angucken
dass wir auf der Höhe der Zeit sind weil
eben Ehrenamt nicht mehr nur im Verein
passiert aber immer noch auch in der
Form sondern in loseren Verbänden in
jungen Initiativen etc die war auch so
ein schutzkorridor brauchen um dann frei
agieren zu können ich bin der
Vorbereitung schönes Beispiel gefunden
ein Dänemark die zweitgrößte dänische
Bank lässt ihre Mitarbeiter in der
Arbeitszeit ehrenamtliche Tätigkeiten
machen das heißt sie werden in der Zeit
voll bezahlt ist das vorstellbar hierher
Ulrich ganz ehrlich ich kenne ja einige
Unternehmen die das so handhaben gerade
die familiengeführten übrigens die sogar
stolz darauf sind dass ihr
Abteilungsleiter oder
die Buchhalterin sich im Rettungsdienst
und in der Feuerwehr engagiert der Punkt
ist leiten wir daraus einen
Rechtsanspruch ab oder nicht ich meine
wenn wir von Engagement sprechen geht
das auch um gewisses Bewusstsein in der
Gesellschaft und ich würde mich freuen
wenn zahlreiche Arbeitgeber mehr diese
Haltung haben ja ich freue mich wenn
auch mal in der Mittagspause sogar
während der Arbeitszeit der eine oder
andere Mitarbeiter sich um sein Ehrenamt
kümmert aber die Menschen die freiwillig
tätig sind und sich freiwillig und
ehrenamtlich engagieren übernehmen ja
häufig Aufgaben von denen man auch sagen
könnte da wäre unter Umständen
vielleicht auch der Staat zuständig es
ist doppelsichtig also wir haben zum
Teil diese Kompensation armutsbereich
Tafeln etc eigentlich ein Skandal dass
es Tafeln gibt und geben muss wir sehen
aber momentan die Zahlen werden immer
höher es funktioniert nicht ohne das hat
auch mit Scheitern von Sozialsystem zu
tun trotzdem und deshalb ist es beides
ist es auch erfüllend für die Menschen
das heißt viele wollen auch ehrenamtlich
arbeiten also es ist beides tatsächlich
manchmal lückenbüßen ganz oft aber die
Lust und die Freude von Menschen sich zu
engagieren und zwar nicht nach Vorgaben
der Politik sondern Eigeninitiative von
den eigenen Verantwortung machen sich
machen sich Kommunen Länder oder auch
der bunten schlanken Fuß in der Hoffnung
dass die Menschen ähm genau das erfüllen
was er denn gerade beschrieben hat
nein das glaube ich nicht Herr Schäfer
aber ich will schon betonen dass gerade
in dem Bereich Rettungsdienst Feuerwehr
und Katastrophenschutz es sich natürlich
um genuin staatliche Aufgaben handelt
die der Staat aber nur deswegen
bewerkstelligen kann weil es im Bereich
des Katastrophenschutzes zahlreiche
ehrenamtliche Kräfte gibt hier
unterstützen ehrenamtliche übrigens mit
ihrer Zeit aber auch teilweise in den
einsetzen mit Gefahr für ihr Leben eine
staatliche Aufgabe für die Gemeinschaft
und da zeigt sich dass bei dem Ehrenamt
eben doch auch das Böckenförde dictum
gilt nämlich dass der Staat von
Voraussetzungen lebt die er selbst nicht
schaffen kann also der Staat lebt von
den ehrenamtlichen im staatlichen
Bereich selbst aber auch der
Zusammenhalt in einer Gesellschaft
nämlich für den anderen Menschen
einzustehen Solidarität zu zeigen keine
kalte egoistische Gesellschaft zu haben
ist Politik für ein demokratisches
Gemeinwesen und das wird durch das
Ehrenamt auch
bewerkstelligtum inhaltlich erklärt
vielleicht müssen Sie noch mal ein
Stichwort geben für all die die damit
nichts mit dem Begriff nichts anfangen
können ja bückenführer ein
Verfassungsrichter und Rechtsprofessor
in
Freiburg und der hat in einer bekannten
Schrift den Satz formuliert der Staat
lebt von Voraussetzungen die er selbst
nicht schaffen kann dieser Satz ist oft
zitiert aber er ist auch vielschichtig
interpretierbar nicht nur im Hinblick
auf geistige moralische Voraussetzung
und sich auch im Hinblick auf das was
Menschen tun um eine Gesellschaft Halt
zu geben und Solidarität und
mitmenschlichkeiten damit auch würde
ihre Geltung zu verschaffen gucken auf
den anderen Punkte in einer große Rolle
spielt bei diesem Bereich wir wenn es
gibt ja jetzt die ehrenamtleren kleinen
also in Kirchengemeinden bei
Sportvereinen etc alles was dazu gehört
aber zunehmend wieder Bedarf an
Freiwilligen auch größer ähm im großen
Krankenhäusern Pflege die Feuerwehr sie
haben sie angesprochen wiederholt und
das vor allem auch von der änderten
Grundvoraussetzungen also wir haben mehr
Naturkatastrophen beispielsweise die
Pandemie war da Kriegsflüchtlinge wo die
Menschen sehr intensiv geholfen haben in
den vergangenen Jahren da kommen die
Freiwilligendienste ins Spiel also rund
100.000 sind das im Jahr die die solche
Dienste leisten und da kommt das
verpflichtende Jahr in die Debatte was
wir im vergangenen Monaten auch
wiederholt gehört haben Dienstpflicht
deutschlanddienst gesellschaftsjahr
viele Namen gibt dafür was ist ihre
Position dazu
intuitiv hatte ich immer meine Grund
Sympathie dafür aber Politik ist ja mehr
als die eigene Intuition und als eigene
innere Schweinehund deshalb habe ich mir
auch immer genau angeguckt auch in
meiner Arbeitsgruppe auch in Gesprächen
Mitarbeiterinnen auch jungen Leuten
gerade was haltet ihr davon und die
Antwort war oft sehr sehr deutlich und
sehr differenziert wir brauchen mehr
Unterstützung wir wollen uns engagieren
das
bundesfreiwilliger der
Bundesfreiwilligendienst das freiwillige
Sozialarbeit muss besser unterstützen
aber bitte
fordert uns kein Pflichtjahr das wird
als Bevormundung begriffen und das nehme
ich sehr ernst ich will nicht an jungen
Leuten vor bei Ihnen ein Dienstjahr auf
oktoyieren dass wer nicht mein
Verständnis sondern es muss ein
gemeinsames Modell gehen weil es ja
gerade auch junge Menschen betrifft wie
wir Freiwilligendienst stärken das wäre
meine Einsatz
[Musik]
sie sind christlich in der christliche
sozialen Union ihre Schwesterpartei die
CDU hat beim letzten Parteitag
mehrheitlich dafür gestimmt dass ein
solches Jahr eingeführt wird wie sieht's
bei ihnen aus wie sehen Sie das es gab
auch Kritik innerhalb der CDU dazu also
es gibt da unterschiedliche Positionen
auch aber wie gesagt mehrheitlich dann
abgestimmt für ein solches ähm die
Debatte auch sehr aufmerksam bei diesem
Sender übrigens wo sonst
verfolgt ich finde es gibt
gefühlsmäßig Argumente die für eine
Dienstpflicht sprechen nämlich es hat
niemanden geschadet sich für das Land
einzusetzen ist doch gut wenn man sich
engagiert aber wenn man die Oberfläche
dieser Argumente wegnimmt dann muss das
aus meiner Sicht bei einem Nein für eine
allgemeine Dienstpflicht bleiben und
zwar aus dem einfachen Grund dass sich
Engagement für die Gesellschaft für den
Mitmenschen letztlich nicht durch Zwang
erzwingen kann sondern das muss aus
einer inneren Haltung kommen und darüber
hinaus und das darf ich dann auch als
Rechtspolitiker sagen sowohl Europarecht
Menschenrechtskonvention als auch unser
Grundgesetz würden das im Augenblick
verbieten zudem wären die Kosten nämlich
einen Verwaltungsapparat aufzubauen um
eine Dienstpflicht umzusetzen und auch
rechtlich durchzusetzen während so hoch
das letztlich ein vernünftiger Staat
davon Abstand nehmen würde letztlich
meine ich muss es mehr Formen geben dass
wir freiwilliges Engagement auch an
freiwilliges Jahr stärker fördern auch
mit Maßnahmen die wir bislang nicht
vorgenommen haben aber ich meine nicht
dass es noch eine Zeit gibt für eine
allgemeine Dienstpflicht wir müssen
abschließen und ganz kurz auch noch mal
auf ihre handlungs- und Tätigkeitsfelder
gucken nämlich auf die Politik wenn wir
auf die kommunale Ebene gucken sich da
sehr viele ehrenamtlich tätig und aber
zunehmend Anfeindungen ausgesetzt das
heißt das Interesse lässt
nachvollziehbar teilweise nach als nicht
nur Anfeindungen sind teilweise auch
Attentate sie kennen das auch be Übungen
aller verschiedenster Art was kann man
tun oder was denken Sie was muss hier
auf dieser Ebene getan werden damit in
diesem Bereich die Menschen wieder mehr
bereit sind da Verantwortung zu
übernehmen die sie ja im Unternehmen
wollen übernehmen wollen ja meine
Enzyklopädie von Morddrohung ist diese
Woche noch mal gewachsen es gibt ja
bestimmte Themen die das leider triggern
und daraus kann ich auch ableiten was
passieren muss also es muss zum einen
sichergestellt wenn das Leute die sich
in Initiativen Verein engagieren auch
kommunalpolitisch zum Beispiel Ihre
Adresse schützen können da gibt es ja
Möglichkeiten die haben wir immer
Hassrede gesetzt in der letzten
Legislatur schon erweitert und zudem ist
einfach Opferschutz notwendig viele
Politiker stehen im Zentrum der
Aufmerksamkeit ich kann mich nicht
beschweren der Staatsschutz unterstützt
mich hervorragend aber vielen die an der
Basis arbeiten geht es nicht so und da
brauchen wir Unterstützung Strukturen
und auch eine bessere Strafverfolgung
dieser Bedrohung denn der Umfang ist
gewaltig man kann sich gar nicht
vorstellen was da tagtäglich passiert
bei Menschen die sich zum Beispiel
geflüchtete gemacht
noch mal in diesem Bereich Demokratie in
unserem Föderalismus beginnt von unten
in den Städten Landkreisen und Gemeinden
und wenn dort sich die Vorfälle häufen
das Stadträte oder BürgermeisterInnen
sich nicht mehr sicher sein können dann
wird damit auch unsere Demokratie
angegriffen und das müssen wir uns vor
Augen führen und ich meine dass hier ein
konzertiertes Vorgehen zwischen
Strafrecht
Aufmerksamkeit in der Gesellschaft aber
auch ganz konkreten Schutz notwendig ist
um die Menschen zu schützen die sich
engagieren aber damit auch insgesamt
demokratisches Engagement zu sichern und
da haben wir ein Thema für das nächste
Jahr ihnen vielen Dank dass Sie bei
diesem mutmaßlich letzten Doppel
Interview bei Phoenix im Bundestag
gebannt in diesem Jahr in diesem Jahr
Gottes sehen bei uns gewesen sind vielen
Dank dafür Ulrich Lindt vielen Dank